(cheers and applause)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love this!
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] You look so great!
- Thank you, you too!
- You're all glowy.
- Thank you.
- Congratulations on all the things
happening in your life right now.
You're just killing it.
(cheers and applause)
You're killing it.
Last time we talked,
it's Christmas time. Last time we talked
about Christmas villages,
like we decorated,
Have you decorated this year?
- I'm halfway up.
My house was under renovation,
so everything was in storage.
They pulled it down,
and I started putting my tree together
and I was like, "Something's missing."
My team thinks I'm crazy
'cause I have a lot of villages,
a lot of houses.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- I'm like, "Something's missing."
And she was like, "You're right!"
My sister had everything pulled down,
and I was like, "I told you!
"The house was missing there."
I know my village!
- [Kelly] Me too.
- What did you add this year?
- So, my son decided,
because we have New York, we have islands,
we have New York and Brooklyn.
- Whoa!
- Yeah, we have a Brooklyn scene.
I was like, "Okay." I was like,
"Maybe next year we'll add Jersey."
I don't know what we're doing.
They're all the Charles Dickens.
It's still the department,
it's still that old school thing.
But he calls them,
my 7-year-old son was like,
"Oh no, that's Brooklyn."
(laughter)
I was like,
"I didn't even know you knew that yet."
"I didn't even know you,"
(laughing)
like, "What?"
But yeah, it's all set.
We're not final. It's not final.
This week is actually,
I'm putting the final touches.
- When I get back, that's
when it's all together.
I'm adding a road.
I added a carousel.
- [Kelly] We have a road.
- A beautiful carousel.
(gasps)
- We don't have a carousel.
- I added an ice skate rink.
- We have an ice skating rink.
- Do you have the water fountain?
- Girl, what? No!
We don't have a water fountain!
- I have the water fountain.
- I don't have a water fountain
and I don't have a carousel.
- [Taraji] I have a police
station and a fire station.
- We have a police
station and fire station.
- Does the car come in and out like this?
- Shut up!
(laughter)
(laughing)
I'm gonna need a picture.
Okay, so what about your childhood?
What's like a favorite Christmas memory?
- Oh, favorite Christmas memory.
I remember one year,
because of me, it was my bright idea.
I'm the creative in the family.
I put together, I was like,
"Let's have a family talent show."
And so, I thought I was gonna win
because, you know, I'm
the talent of the family.
(laughter)
I sang, um, "Angel"
by um, uh,
♪ Angel ♪
Anita Baker! God, I drew a blank.
Thanks!
Then my uncles came in
and they blew the roof off the house
with the Temptations song.
- Oh, which one?
♪ It's Merry Christmas and Happy New, ♪
Cause I have an uncle with the very,
why can't I think of songs today?
Say that again.
Silent Night, yes! Silent Night.
- No one's ever heard of it.
- No, right.
It's a new song apparently.
- So they kicked your behind.
- They killed it.
They totally stole the show.
Literally, we talk about it to this day.
I mean, this was when I was 12.
I'm 53. We're still talking
about this moment.
- Oh my God, wait.
Wait, I totally thought you meant
you did this as an adult.
- No!
- And you were like,
"I wanted everyone to do a talent show
"'cause I was gonna win."
- [Taraji] I did.
- I was just picturing you at like 35,
just like, I've got my Anita Baker.
(laughing)
Okay, I love it.
It would've been better
if you would've been 35.
So what's one of your favorite
Christmas memories with your son?
- [Taraji] Oh, God!
- He's older now, but,
- No, he's grown now, but,
I loved when they're little bits.
When they're little,
little, little, because,
but you know, that's my baby.
He's so grown now.
I produced that play on Broadway,
"Jaja's African Hair Braiding."
(applause and cheering)
- [Kelly] That's so awesome,
to see his mama killing it.
- Yes, he was so proud.
He really was proud.
- I have the young age still,
so it is kind of still fun.
- It's fun!
You know, I think we have
more fun than they do,
like putting the toys
together the night before.
But my son was funny.
He liked what he liked.
He would pick like two or three things.
I swear, I think I picked the wrong
baby up at the hospital.
(laughter)
But he would pick like four toys,
and that's all he wanted.
I would buy him like 12, thinking,
"He wants this, he wants this."
- This is me with my children.
- He hurt my feelings,
because I would watch him open the gifts
and he would be like, "Eh, oh."
He would get those four
gifts that he asked for,
grab those up and go in his room,
and all the other stuff
I bought is just sitting
outside and under the tree.
- I can beat this.
I can beat this.
My kids don't even open them all.
(laughter)
There's not that many.
You know what I'm saying?
They will literally open,
once they find something they like,
they just go play with it.
- [Taraji] They're gone.
- I'm like, "I'm sorry.
"I spent a lot of time doing this."
- [Taraji] Exactly.
- Yes.
(laughing)
- These kids, they're so privileged.
- I'm like, "What?"
They do not know what it's like.
Anyway.
And we worked hard for that, but whatever.
(cheering and applause)
That was a look at her new
movie, The Color Purple.
That is an intense,
I was telling her, I was like,
"My thighs hurt from watching this clip."
- Yes!
(laughter)
- You're on that table. It looks fun.
Sometimes when you have alcohol in you,
you don't know until the next day.
But when you don't have alcohol in you,
it feels like you're snowboarding.
Yeah, your thighs burn.
- No, everything was burning.
(laughter)
And what you did not see is that I was,
I had to ice my knees
in between every take.
- How many takes? How many times a day?
- Listen,
Oprah has seen all of the footage
from every angle, and she counted.
She said I climbed up
on that table 88 times.
(audience wooing)
But your adrenaline goes.
I wasn't counting.
- I don't think so, no.
- 88 times.
- [Kelly] No.
- [Taraji] And I don't have
Meg the Stallion knees.
(laughter)
I'm climbing up there
and I'm dropping it low, child.
(audience wooing) (applause)
- I was like, "Woo!"
That right there, in
the heels, by the way.
- Yeah, they were character shoes though.
They were character shoes.
- Who cares?
They're not flat.
- They're not flat.
You're absolutely right.
No, it was a lot of work.
- What was it like for you?
I can't imagine seeing this as a kid
and then now you're in it, right?
- I never imagined myself in it.
I just remember seeing the movie in 1985.
I was 15,
and I had been,
that's when the acting bug awakened in me
and I was like, "I think
I want to do that."
I remember going to the theater and seeing
all those black faces, and I saw me.
That allowed me to dream.
That allowed me to go,
"Hey, I can do that."
And so shortly after that,
I started really getting
serious about acting.
Then when I got into
college, I read the book
and I was like, "Whoo."
I mean, you know,
Alice Walker did a great thing.
This is like one of the cornerstone
pieces of literature of American culture.
Everybody knows this movie,
white, black, it doesn't matter.
It transcends race, color, religion.
- It's a phenomenon.
- It is, and everybody
can really see themselves
in some of these characters.
What I love about it is, with this film,
we're gonna be breaking
generational curses,
healing families,
hopefully.
Because a lot of us were
healed doing this film.
You think you got over some things, and
here you are faced with
a character that has,
and then you have to kind of take the
bandaid off of something
you thought that healed.
Art can be really healing, you know?
It really can.
- [Kelly] Did you dive
into the character? Did
you relate it at all?
(applause)
- You know,
I did, because she was literally
the cookie of the 1920s.
- [Kelly] I know!
- [Taraji] No, literally,
she got off the plantation and was like,
"I'm gonna make something of myself."
You gotta remember, this film, this movie,
the book opens up,
it's the first generation of freed slaves.
So a lot of slaves was like,
"Well, we free, but where we going?"
They were still sharecropping and minding
the land that they were living on.
This one decided, I'm going to break free
and I'm gonna make something of myself.
And so, she was a change maker.
Every time she came on a
scene, she lifted this,
she lifted it, and everybody,
I had a journalist say,
"She's almost like an alien
"that comes down from outer space."
And that's how the town treats her.
It's like a big deal when Shug Avery
comes to town because
the people that she left
behind didn't have dreams,
or if they did, they were deferred.
She didn't allow her
dreams to be deferred.
- Yeah, she was afraid,
people were afraid to dream that big.
- Exactly.
She was the dreamer,
and she came back and changed lives.
- I feel like this is you.
I feel like you're that person too.
Every time I run into
you, you're such a light.
Every time you come,
(Taraji gasps)
You are that person though.
- Thank you.
- When you enter a room,
(applause)
- Thank you.
- It couldn't have been cast
more perfectly.
- [Taraji] Thank you.
- When it comes to talking about injustice
or racism, things like that,
I have friends,
they have to talk to
their kids differently
than I had to have a talk with my kids.
Did you feel that with
your boy growing up?
- Oh, absolutely.
- [Kelly] Even now, at 30.
- Oh, even to this day.
I mean, I think any black
mother, grandmother,
niece, auntie, we worry
about our black men.
We worry about,
if they leave the house,
will they come back?
It's something that lives
in our subconscious.
It's just there.
We carry it well, but it's always there.
Especially when you're triggered
by something on the
news or you're scrolling
Instagram and some kid
has been unjustly arrested
or shot or something.
It sends a shock wave,
not only through you,
but through the entire community
because we feel it.
We feel it as one unit.
Am I lying?
- [Audience Member] No!
(Taraji laughing) (applause)
And also, even as a,
I mean, I can't imagine
the next step of that.
But even as a parent,
you always worry anyway.
- [Taraji] Always.
- There's that fear anyway.
You want 'em to fly, you want 'em to soar,
you want 'em to do stuff.
I'm afraid of people sometimes
outside my house.
- Yeah, exactly.
It's just that extra layer of,
will he be protected by the law?
You know?
- Man.
- It's tough, but, I don't,
- I love that he has,
y'all are sitting there though,
with that playbill, and it's your show,
and you're doing it. I just love,
to show him what a successful
boss mom looks like.
- Oh, he's very proud.
(applause)
- I know, but that's like,
'cause you've also set the bar
for whatever relationships he's gonna have
in the future. You know what I'm saying?
I don't think we realize that
until you become a parent.
You're like, "Oh man,
we're setting the bar
"for our kids. They're watching us.
"I wanna show 'em what love looks like,
"what success looks like,
"what happiness looks like."
You're doing such a great job.
- Thank you so much.
(applause)
- [Kelly] It's so cool.
- [Taraji] Thank you.
(laughing) Thank you.
(cheers and applause)
- Anyway, I know that you like games.
I know that you're competitive.
I'm competitive, so I feel like we
should play a Christmas game.
- Okay.
(cheers and applause)
Well we've got a Christmas
game coming up next.
Y'all, The Color Purple's in theaters
starting Christmas day.
We'll be right back.